hello everyone and welcome to the new
good stuff it's the Paul Morphy saga and
we are back at the first American just
Congress in a third game between James
Thompson and Paul Charles Murphy now in
the first two games Morphy won both
games and then Thompson requested well
sort of a time out he said that he
needed to to a two-day break at perhaps
the regain strength or who knows I don't
think they asked why he did it and this
is now a game Game three but morpheme in
those two days he played a lot of chess
games and well we don't have any exact
knowledge on how he played those games
but we can only assume that he pretty
much destroyed everyone that being said
let's check out game three against again
Thompson with the white pieces and since
Morphy already won two games he only
needs one more win to cause the match as
it's a five games best of three so II
for like in game like in Game one we've
a five by morphine Knight of three we
have Knight to c6 and Bishop to c4 the
Italian game and Morphy once again
replies with the jacobian or Bishop to
c5
we have c3 again a shame not going not
going for the Evans gambit it's
something you should always do if your
opponent gives you this opportunity we
have c3 and now Knight to f6 our
continuing development attacking d4 pawn
d3 defending ends now d6
we have h3 taking away the g4 Square for
more fees pieces and Bishop to e6 now
threatening to pick up the c4 bishop
massive White's pawn structure let's go
back to b3 and now this position has
been reached after this game many times
and a lot of moves were played here but
the move morphic plays d5 has never
again been played after this game so
really exciting stuff if your opponent
allows it you should always always play
d5 so we have e captures Bishop captures
on d5 now saying okay if you capture I
get a nice free development for my queen
so here Thompson just castles morphic
castles and Bishop to g5 makes sense
develop the developer piece as far into
your opponent's position as possible
while pinning the night and here more
feet decides to trade one
the bishop character son be three point
being that if Queen captures you can
capture the d3 pawn for example Queen
captures Queen captures now on d3 and
now you don't you don't want to go for
Queen captures on b7 right away
it could be could be a bit dangerous
although even even if it's not Queen d7
maybe you can start kicking away the
Queen either way you've traded a central
pawn for a beep on so not something you
want to do so instead after Bishop
captures n b3 with a capture son b3
which isn't bad for white of course he
gets a semi-open file for his rook and
now h6 saying do you wanna trade on f6
or do you wanna bring the bishop back
here bishop to h4 was played and now
morphe says that it is okay in this
position to push g5 so g5 attacking the
bishop bishop to g3 and now morphe
continues with with the attack with
efore here morphe says that if captures
then he can just capture back and that
this position is well pretty much
excellent for him because let's say we
have a queen trait captures captures and
now you do have some issues with your
with your f2 fun bunch of characters and
g3z
Knight captures and g3 is a threat
because the F pawn is pinned so let's
say captures rook the rook attacks
brusha back to e5 but now you have this
very nice tactic of Knight captures on
f2 and the tactics really do work in
more fees favor
now if row captures of course a rogue d1
check King has to move you pick up the
rook and so on so this is a good
decision by Morpheus efore idea as it
like we've just shown tactics work in
his favor so tonight's the e5 getting
the knight out of the way also defending
d3 so now Knight captures on e5 Bishop
captures and eek actress on d3 are
creating a passed pawn on d3 and
Thompson of course doesn't want to let
this pawn you know exist any longer so
Bishop captures an f6 Queen captures on
f6 and now Queen captures on d3 grabbing
back the pawn so the material is equal
however now morphe gets some insane
development rook 8d it comes with an
attack on the Queen Queen back to c2 and
now look f8 and all of more of these
pieces are full
operational whereas Thompson's pieces
are not really doing all that much and
it's not easy to develop you could try
something like 93 for example if Knight
here just rookie two wins the game on
the spot you either lose the knight or
or you start losing on f2 because
there's a triple attack here so not easy
to develop so Thompson tries b4 makes
room for a knight on a three and then
prepares Knight to c4 we have bishop
backs back to be six nights to a three
now going for a c4 and now an incredibly
strong move by morphe Queen to f4 Quinta
for preventing Knight to c4 but also
making preparations for c6 Bishop to c7
and then Bishop from c7 and the Queen
could post some some problems here on
the Kings side we have rook eight to d1
now starting to develop and now c6
continuing with the plan and here well I
there are a few ways you could continue
maybe c4 is an idea by a fall by c5 and
then after Bishop d7 you can block with
g3 none of these ideas are great for
white but they're better than what
Thompson played Thompson played rook to
d3
okay you have a nice nice coverage of
the third-ranked also may be repairing
rook after d1 to double up rooks and the
D file you're offering a trade of one of
the rooks however it doesn't really work
here Thompson was probably working or
something like Bishop to c7 g3 you push
away the Queen and then the game simply
continues you can maybe trade you can
double up here all works well for white
however morphe had something else in
mind
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find what morphe played here well
I'll give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it our
congratulations and finding such a such
a nice idea we already discussed
discussed it a bit but ever since
Thompson moved one of the rooks from the
back rank this became possible so for
those of you who just want to enjoy show
Bishop characters on f2 with check point
being if rook captures the rook to e1
with check and it's game over
rook f1 you can go to h2 the Queen
blocks the h2 square so here and rook
captures and f1 will be checkmate
so instead after Bishop captures an F -
okay Thompson played King th1 but now
rook captures and III Queen captures and
rook to e3 more if he prepares a deadly
idea so now the Queen is under attack
the Queen moves with tempo Queen to d8
with Chuck King to g7 and now Thompson
decided to trade Queens with Queen to d4
check because there's a lot going on
here for example if you try a slow move
like night to see do you attack the rook
do you see were the Morphy had in mind
so it's actually a force made in four so
again feel free to pause the video and
try to spot it so for those of you who
are able to do it congratulations and
spotting such such beautiful mating for
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy a show rook captures an h3 with
check that's the idea behind the more
physical key to remove G captures now
Queen f3 check King has the mocking h2
now Queen g3 check King h1 and Queen
captures on h3 is mate as the bishop
covers the G 1 square so here at
Thompson says ok I don't really have a
lot of options here Queen d4 check
offers a queen trade but now Queen
captures more features trades C captures
and rook the e2 defending the bishop
also now this is an idea capturing here
is an idea and Morpheus position is just
much better here we have Knight c4 going
for Knight f5 ended the b7 pawn but
morphe decides that now it's even time
to trade rooks instead of just going for
for something like Bishop captures here
and then can along stand counter play
maybe with with Knight to d6 going after
f7 and so on so rook e1 by morphe rook
captures Bishop captures and now this
point is under attack you cannot defend
it so Knights the a5 going after b7 you
cannot push then you lose c6 but Bishop
captures on b4 we have Knight captures
on b7 and now more if he starts bringing
the King into the game 98 goes after c6
but now c5 we have Knight to c6 attacks
the bishop so you cannot capture here
but now King e6
with D captures and c5 from Bishop
characters and now g4 keeping an eye on
Morpheus King side pawns
but now comes King to d5 attacks the
knight Knight back to d8 goes after the
pawn here but now f6 and now more fees
up upon his King is much more active
with the knight doesn't really have a
lot of good squares here it's it's you
know looking bleak at best for for good
Thompson here kingi to with a5 now more
free wants to push a for to control the
be three square he wants to keep this
pawn on a dark square so it remains a
target key of three we have a for now
next move more free will go after the
pawn king e2 and now Bishop the d4 very
important he wants to create a passed
pawn here King ds3 Thompson will try to
create some sort of a blockade with the
king but Bishop captures and b2 we have
nice to b7 now this is a one way to read
you the pawn before before it Queen's
Queen better back the e5 sorry
butter back the e5 and now King to see -
we have King to see for now Knight to d8
we have a three and now Knight back to
b7 now going for this check followed by
Knight to b3 but morphic calculates
properly we have a - but now Knights the
a5 with check King has the move but King
before attacks the knight and the
Knights the b3 and here there are a few
ways you can end this game or if he
chooses the the most elegant one he
plays King to a3 he puts a Thompson in
suits wand and it was in his position on
mo 46 that James Thompson resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here you cannot move the King because
you lose the night if you lose if you
move the knight then you allow a one
Queen so you can basically the only
thing you can do is push some points
here give up give up some points and
then black will very surely push those
points and win the game this way
so of course Thompson didn't go for this
after this King to 8th remove he
resigned the game and Morphy wins the
match 3 to 0 now Louis Paulsen also won
his match against Calthrop 3 to 0 so
both of them had a very nice match and
this is what I mentioned during Game one
it was a it was on Friday that
Paulsen created this well spectacled he
said that he will play four simultaneous
games a blindfold against the well most
of the times when a master of the
simultaneous exhibition it will be
against weak players so you know he of
course you a grandmaster cannot play a
blindfold simultaneous game against
other grandmasters but here Paulson
actually invited more feet to join in to
be one of those four seats and Morphy
gladly accepted but morphe said only
only if I also play blindfold so two of
them agreed and well as they read on
Friday they will play on Saturdays so
this will be the next game we show
before we continue with the with the
first American chess congress so stay
tuned it's gonna be it's gonna be really
exciting and also after agreeing to that
the two of them played one game it is
said that it was a private game the
moves were not made public and they said
that the first-ever game between Murphy
and Paulson after six hours ended in a
draw now if this is so or not maybe it
was I mean I have no reason to doubt
that it that actually happened I would
be very interesting to see that game
although the moves were not published
but yeah just so you know you know if
your friends at the bar in the library
ask you about it the first ever game
between Murphy and Paulson ended in a
draw even though we don't know the moves
to that game but yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it a next game the
first ever game between Paulson and
Murphy in a blindfold settings in a
blindfold setting now I would like to
thank Nicolas reward coaching and edema
Shahzad Fida
David M stole Bernard on Ronnie and my
club hours for a contributor to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here I'm thankful
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the Paul Morphy saga with the
first American chest congress continue
to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day